disait le premier ministre et johnson
c'était comme la rentrée des classes et
on était heureux de retrouver tous les
copains et voilà l'ambiance qui régnait
dans la salle de réunion aujourd'hui
nous ouvrons un nouveau chapitre pour
l'alliance nous avons abordé des
questions structurantes pour notre
sécurité nous avons pris les décisions
d'une grande ampleur
le président bart hayden affirmé
l'attachement des états unis à l'otan et
de la part des autres alliés nous avons
entendu un attachement tout aussi fort à
notre alliance et tout cela dans une ère
de compétition mondiale et nos
dirigeants reconnaissent la nécessité
pour l'europe et l'amérique du nord
d'être unis au sein de l'otan afin de
défendre nos valeurs et nos intérêts
cela surtout à un moment où des régimes
autoritaires tels que la russie et la
chine met à mal l'ordre international
fondé sur des règles les alliés se
félicite de ces consultations avec le
président baden l'avait 200 rencontré
avec le président poutine à genève
nos relations avec la russie sont au
plus bas depuis la guerre froide elle et
les actes agressifs que la russie menace
notre sécurité
l'otan reste attaché à notre double
approche fondée à la fois sur la défense
et le dialogue
nous allons assurer la force nos moyens
de défense tout en restant disposé au
dialogue afin d'expliquer nos positions
afin d'éviter des malentendus et
d'éviter toute escalade
nous soutenons pleinement la décision de
prolongation du nouveau traité start et
nous nous féliciterons de nouveaux
pourparlers stratégiques sur le
dispositif futur de maîtrise des
armements tout en assurant la kz
concertation ici au sein de l'otan et il
nous sommes solidaires avec nos estimés
pays partenaires l'ukraine et la géorgie
et nous allons continuer à accompagner
ces pays dans la voie des réformes qui
les rov approche de l'otan au sommet
nous avons évoqué aujourd'hui la chine
nous voyons une grande convergence de
vues entre alliés
chef en fonction de nos intérêts nous
voyons des possibilités d'engagement sur
des questions telles que la maîtrise des
armements et le changement climatique
en revanche l'influencé croissante de la
chine etc politique extérieure présente
des défis pour la sécurité de l'alliance
les dirigeants ont reconnu la nécessité
de faire face ensemble de tels défis en
tant qu'alliance ils ont convenu aussi
de la nécessité de s'engager la chine
pour défendre nos intérêts en matière de
sécurité nous voyons les politiques de
coercition de la chine qui en porte à
faux par rapport aux valeurs
fondamentales consacré dans le traité de
washington la chine se dote 2 rapidement
de nouveaux moyens nucléaires de plus de
givet de systèmes de vecteurs de
lancement très évolué la chine fait
preuve d'une opacité dans la mise en
oeuvre de la modernisation de ses moyens
militaires
la chine collabore avec la russie sur le
plan militaire notamment en organisant
des exercices conjoints dans la zone
euro-atlantique et nous restons inquiets
quand nous voyons aussi la
désinformation de la chine
les dirigeants de l'otan appellent la
chine à respecter ses engagements
internationaux et à agir de manière
responsable au sein du système
international y compris dans l'espace et
dans les domaines de cyber et maritime
cela conformément à son rôle de grande
puissance
les dirigeants d'adopter notre programme
ambitieux l'agenda autant 2030 qui a
vocation à donner à l'alliance les
moyens de faire face aux défis aux
menaces du présent et de l'avenir et
nous avons pris des décisions dans huit
secteurs nous avons tout d'abord convenu
de renforcer l'otan en tant que forum de
consultation transatlantique et
d'actions communes sur toutes les
questions relatives à notre sécurité et
nous avons convenu de renforcer et
d'élargir
nos consultations et notre concertation
politique deuxio nous avons convenu de
renforcer notre dispositif de dissuasion
et de défense à cette fin il nous allons
renforcer l'otan comme cadre de la
défense de la zone euro atlantique et
nous allons nous avons renouvelé notre
attachement à l'engagement en matière
d'investissement par la défense
intervenu en 2014
troisièmement nous avons convenu de
renforcer la résilience de nos sociétés
les chefs des pays de l'otan ont décidé
de se doter d'objectifs à l'échelle de
l'otan et d'objectifs nationaux concrets
destinés à protéger nos infrastructures
essentielles
quatrièmement nous avons décidé
d'affûter une autre supériorité
technologique
les alliés ont décidé de lancer un
accélérateur des innovations en matière
de défense pour la mairie pour
l'atlantique nord sous l'acronyme diana
ce centre de concert avec les startups
et l'industrie favorisera la coopération
transatlantique pour prévenir tout écart
entre alliés et les alliés ont décidé de
mettre sur pied un fonds d'innovation de
l'otan font qu'il devra investir dans
les startups qui travaille à la mise au
point de technologies émergentes et de
rupture de moyens pour contrer celle ci
cinquièmement nous allons intensifier
les efforts pour sauvegarder l'ordre
international fondé sur des règles
à cette fin nous allons renforcer nos
liens de partenariat avec les pays de
l'asie-pacifique dont l'australie le
japon la nouvelle-zélande et la corée du
sud et nous allons vouloir tisser de
nouveaux liens avec des pays de
l'amérique latine l'afrique et de l'asie
nous sommes aussi attaché à approfondir
davantage nos liens de coopération avec
l'union européenne
sixièmement nous allons renforcer
sensiblement nos activités de formation
et de renforcement des capacités au
profit de pays partenaires tels que
l'ukraine la géorgie l'irak et la
jordanie
septièmement les dirigeants sont
convenus pour la première fois qu
étudier les conséquences sécuritaires du
changement climatique d'en faire une
tâche
ils structurantes pour l'otan il s'agira
d'étudier périodiquement l'incidence du
changement climatique sur nos
installations mission une autre activité
nous allons intégrer les changements
climatiques à nos exercices et à nos
plans de défense ainsi qu'à nos
démarches d'acquisition et nous allons
nous doter d'une méthode d'évaluation
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
engendrées par les activités militaires
et je me félicite de pouvoir annoncer
que tous les alliés ont marqué leur
volonté leur ferme volonté de réduire
les émissions militaires et nous avons
fixé des objectifs concrets pour
permettre à l'otan de contribuer à
l'atteinte de l'objectif d'émissions
acte zéro d'ici 2050
je remercie le premier ministre justin
trudeau et le canada d'abord proposé
d'accueillir un nouveau centre
d'excellence de l'otan consacrée au
climat et à la sécurité
enfin nous avons décidé d'élaborer le
nouveau concept stratégique de l'otan
d'ici le sommet de l'otan en 2022
nous réaffirmons nos valeurs et nous
tenons compte des évolutions
considérables de l'environnement
sécuritaire est survenu depuis dix ans
l'agenda autant 2030 établi un niveau
d'ambition élevé et tracent la voie à
suivre pour l'adaptation de l'alliance
les alliés reconnaissent que ces
décisions doivent s'accompagner de
ressources adéquates recueillies grâce
aux efforts de défense nationaux et
grâce au fonds commun de l'otan pour la
septième année d'affilée
nous voyons les budgets de défense ce à
quoi cre parmi les alliés européens le
canada nous avons s'ajouter 260
milliards de l'areas obligeait défense
depuis 2014
les alliés se dote nouvelles capacités
et contribue aux missions et aux
opérations de l'otan
tout cela permet un partage plus
équitable du fardeau à l'échelle de
l'alliance et nous devons garder cet
élan afin d'en faire plus ensemble les
alliés ont reconnu la nécessité
d'investir davantage ensemble dans
l'otan
pour avoir et nous avons reconnu la
nécessité de le doter des ressources
nécessaires pour faire face à un
environnement de sécurité plus difficile
donc sur les trois budgets de l'otan
militaires civiles et d'infrastructures
il nous faudra bonifier les ressources
notamment pour pouvoir organiser
davantage d'activités conjointes de
formation et d'exercices pour renforcer
notre dispositif de commandement de
contrôle pour renforcer nos cyberdéfense
pour prépositionné des équipements
renforcer nos infrastructures et offrir
davantage de possibilités de
renforcement des capacités à nos
partenaires en adoptant ainsi c'est
peut-être agenda autant 2030 les alliés
ont pris les décisions voulues pour que
l'otan soit plus fortes et mieux
adaptées à l'avenir
nous avons pris aussi les décisions sur
nos nouveaux domaines opération savoir
domaine si belle que l'espace extra
atmosphérique
les alliés ont adopté une nouvelle
politique de cyberdéfense pour
l'alliance qui acte le fait que le
cyberespace et sans sans cesse 1
n'est ce pas contester cette nouvelle
politique nous donnera la possibilité
d'avoir les capacités technologiques
fortes ainsi que les consultations
politiques et les plans militaires
nécessaires pour que nos systèmes
restent protégés l'otan affiche aussi sa
volonté de se défendre dans l'espace de
manière aussi efficace qu'elle le fait
dans les autres domaines terre mer air
et cyber et je remercie le luxembourg
d'abord proposé de financer la mise en
place d'un système de connaissance de la
situation spatiale stratégique ici au
siège de l'otan
nous avons évoqué aussi l'afghanistan
aux termes de pas loin de deux décennies
les opérations militaires s'achèvent en
afghanistan nous rendons hommage à tous
ceux qui ont été blessés ou consentie
l'ultime sacrifice et nous témoignons de
notre reconnaissance envers tous ceux
qui ont servi sous le drapeau de l'otan
les dirigeants des pays de l'otan
affirment leur volonté de rester
solidaire avec l'afghanistan nous allons
proposer des possibilités de formation
ainsi qu'un soutien financier aux forces
et aux institutions de l'afghanistan et
nous
offriront aussi des moyens financiers
pour assurer l'exploitation de
l'aéroport international
donc nous avons pris des décisions pour
que l'otan soit plus forte dans un monde
de plus concurrentiel et nous avons
tracé la voie à suivre pour l'alliance
au cours de la prochaine décennie et
au-delà j'attends vos questions tout
d'abord reuters
au milieu là bas microphone allez-y
général je reviens sur deux sujets vous
avez parlé des fonds communs vous avez
souvent évoqué vos ambitions à ce propos
pourrait vous le préciser est ce que
l'on va augmenter les fonds communs pour
les opérations militaires et sur un
autre sujet sur l'afghanistan
est ce qu'on a et est d'accord pour
qu'un pays assume l'exploitation de
l'aéroport de kaboul est ce qu'il s'agit
de la turquie en l'occurrence dans le
vide la proposition originale était de
renforcer uniquement le budget militaire
la décision aujourd'hui est de renforcer
les trois budgets
parce que il y a trois budgets au titre
du financement comment il ya le budget
civile le budget militaire et l'obligé
infrastructures qui sont les trois
budgets que nous avons à l'otan autres
décisions tous budgets confondus
nous devons être dans la tranche haute
de notre niveau d'ambition nous avons
donc besoin de fonds supplémentaires
pour pouvoir doté en ressources le
niveau d'ambition élevé que nous nous
sommes fixés ceci s'applique aux trois
budgets et les activités comme plus
d'exercices plus d'entraînements mieux
plus et mieux de commandement et de
contrôle équipements prépositionné
investissements capacitaires mais aussi
sur le budget civile par exemple
travaillé aux côtés des partenaires et
appuyer les partenaires de quelques
manières que ce soit
donc voila cela affecte l'ensemble de
l'agenda autant 2030
et ce qui est important c'est que nous
avons décidé que nous allons renforcer
et adapter l'alliance en faisant plus
ensemble et si nous voulons faire plus
ensemble nous devons avoir plus
d'investissements pour travailler
ensemble et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne puis que saluer que
l'accord soit aujourd'hui sur les trois
budgets et pas seulement sur le budget
militaire qui était la décision
originale et puis autre question
s'est-elle afghanistan je pense oui
effectivement
l'otan et les alliés travaillent
maintenant à la manière dont le
fonctionnement de l'aéroport
international de kaboul pourra être
assurée à l'avenir cela a été mentionné
au sommet aujourd'hui la turquie joue un
rôle essentiel dans ses efforts nous
travaillons aux modalités précises mais
c'est vrai que c'est un engagement fort
et de l'otan et de ses alliés que de
veiller à pouvoir continuer à faire
fonctionner un rapport interne à
international c'est important pour la
poursuite de la présence civil de l'otan
en afghanistan mais aussi pour la
communauté internationale d'où nos
efforts tu le dit m
nous donnons la parole le tpa
à l'arrière de la salle à droite merci
monsieur le secrétaire général a non le
communiqué l'otan nous dit qu'elle
souhaite maintenir un dialogue
constructif avec la chine là où c'est
possible
qu'allez-vous donc faire pour permettre
ce dialogue est ce qu une possibilité
serait de mettre sur pied un conseil
otan chine par exemple merci
premièrement nous avons un dialogue nous
avons des contacts avec la chine
aujourd'hui au niveau de militaires mais
aussi au niveau politique et
diplomatique j'ai rencontré ya pas très
longtemps le ministre des affaires
étrangères chinois nous avons donc
diverses manières de continuer à
entretenir ce dialogue avec la chine
mais par exemple s'agissant des
questions qui tournent autour de la
maîtrise des armements ou de la
situation en afghanistan à à la
frontière chinoise
ce sont autant de questions qu'il est de
notre intérêt commun à l'otan et à la
chine de maintenir le dialogue
l'otan a parcouru énormément de chemin
et c'est ce qu'il ya lieu de retenir la
première fois que nous avons mentionné
la chine dans un communiqué dans une
décision des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement c'était il ya 18 mois au
sommet de londres avant pas un mot sur
la chine et dans le concept stratégique
la chine n'est pas mentionné une seule
fois lisait le communiqué eh bien vous
verrez une véritable convergence entre
alliés où nous abordons l'importance de
prendre contact avec la chine qui n'est
pas notre adversaire mais aussi
d'aborder avec elle les défis des
investissements de la chine dans de
nouvelles ogives nucléaires de nouveaux
vecteurs de ces ogives une certaine
attitude coercitive de la part de la
chine mais aussi une vision différente
de la nôtre par rapport à la sécurité
donc si vous lisez
l'ensemble de ces documents eh bien vous
verrez que nous avons parcouru
énormément de chemin dégager une
position commune sur la chine ce qui est
important pour notre sécurité et
j'ajouterai une chose et c'est lié à ce
que nous faisons chez nous c'est à dire
assumer la responsabilité que nous avons
de défendre tous les alliés des menaces
d'où qu'elles viennent parce que nous
voyons que la chine se rapproche de nous
dans le cyberespace en afrique dans
l'arctique
elle essaye de contrôler nos
infrastructures on a parlé de la 5g et
donc ce que nous faisons dans l'agenda
autant 2030 est particulièrement
pertinent pour la manière d'aborder le
problème de la chine avec plus de
résilience plus de technologie et toutes
les choses que nous allons mettre en
place ensemble
3 questions pour tenter de se simplifier
la vie washington post tout d'abord
merci levé l'américaine merci mes albums
washington post une question pourriez
vous comparez votre expérience de ce
sommet est tout particulièrement notre
expérience avec la délégation américaine
à l'expérience que vous avez eue lors du
précédent sommet avec le président trump
est ce que le président bailly donald pu
vous donner des arguments pour
convaincre pour vous convaincre que
trump ne reviendra pas à la maison
blanche dans quelques années pour
replacer cette eau pour redonner cette
approche comprend stationnaire les
choses sont différentes et l'important
pour moi c'est de faire passer un
message tout à fait clair qui a été
d'ailleurs passé à la réunion
d'aujourd'hui qui est que les alliés
salue l'engagement ferme du président
biden sur le lien transatlantique est le
lien entre l'europe et l'amérique du
nord et les autres alliés le canada
l'europe ont exprimé ce même engagement
fort que le président byden nous devons
nous serrer les coudes à l'otan dans un
monde où il y a plus de concurrence
c'est le message que nous a livré le
président biden
il me l'avait déjà dit à la maison
blanche il y a eu huit semaines et c'est
ce qu'a réitérée l'administration
américaine par la bouche du président
biden en salles aujourd'hui ce que nous
avons appris ces quatre dernières années
ce fut l'importance d'institutions
multilatérales forte en des temps
incertains
parce que l'otan l'alliance atlantique
cette institution elle transcende les
leaders politiques individuelles
elle peut résister aux différents orages
de la politique ce qui prouvait atteste
une fois encore l'importance d'avoir un
lien transatlantique forte fort et il y
aura des leaders politiques élus dans
tous les pays de l'alliance dans les
années à venir
mais tant que nous nous rendons compte
que qu'il est dans notre intérêt de
sécurité nationale que d'être ensemble
et bien l'otan sera la solution pour
notre sécurité est elle en sortira
grandie je salue aussi le fait que à
l'heure actuelle nous avons un soutien
dans les deux parties pour l'otan et si
vous regardez les sondages d'opinion
publiées ces dernières semaines
et bien cela confirme un soutien pour
l'otan et en amérique du nord et en
europe donc je ne peux pas vous dire qui
sera le prochain leader politique dans
les trente pays qui sont membres de
l'alliance mais ce que nous avons vu une
fois de plus à l'oeuvre c'est la force
d'institutions telles que l'otan qui
peuvent justement à résister aux orages
politiques et aux divergences d'opinion
de leur leader sur toute une série de
questions et on l'a vu d'ailleurs au fil
des années
bonjour veaux télévision allemand de
monsieur le secrétaire général vous avez
à plusieurs reprises utilisé le terme
politique de coercition c'est quelque
chose qu'on retrouve aussi dans le
communiqué vous utilisez donc des termes
plus forts que le sommet du g7 pourquoi
est-ce que l'évaluation est différente
deuxièmement qu'elle sous les lignes à
ne pas franchir pour la chine si elle
est franchie c'est comment est-ce
qu'elle passerait au statut d'adversaire
ou de menaces
ce qui est important pour moi c'est que
nous ayons une position unie clair à 30
sur la chine et que je les dis c'est
beaucoup de chemin parcouru pour le
temps puisqu'il y à 18 mois on ne
parlait même pas de la chine
et comme à l'accoutumée lorsque 30
alliés doivent se mettre d'accord
nous devons équilibrer les choses nous
devons aussi aplanir certaines
divergences de vues qui sont l'apanage
nationale mais un l'otan effectivement
en dépit des différences nous nous
essayons autour d'une table et nous
produisons un message clair et univoque
comme c'est le cas sur le dossier alors
je fais un commentaire sur la
déclaration de l'otan qui est forte qui
est précise mais nous ne sommes pas ici
pour comparer ce que nous disons nous
sommes avec d'autres nous sommes ici
pour dire que la chine et bientôt sera
bientôt la plus grande économie au monde
que c'est aussi le second plus grand
budget de défense au monde et la plus
grande à marine au monde la chine
investit lourdement dans de nouvelles
capacités notamment des technologies de
rupture les systèmes autonomes
la reconnaissance faciale l'intelligence
artificielle et installe tout cela dans
de nouveaux systèmes d'armement qui
change la nature de la guerre telle que
nous la connaissions auparavant
ce progrès colossal s'est avancé
colossal et c'est important pour nous et
le nier serait une erreur donc la
question n'est pas de savoir comment on
la borne mais si on aborde deuxième rang
merci monsieur le secrétaire général les
dirigeants ukrainiens qui ont des
attentes assez forte pour ce qui est du
map du plan d'action d'adhésion je lis
le communiqué du sommet je vois qu'on
n'y est pas encore à la suite de ce
sommet donc quel sera votre message
principal envoyé aux dirigeants et au
peuple ukrainien merci match de sommeil
mon message essentiel c'est que l'otan
est solidaire de l'ukraine nous
apportons un soutien politique fort la
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine nous apportons une aide
pratique nous mettons d'ailleurs les
bouchées doubles sur cette aide pratique
dans le cadre de l'alliance dans le
contexte de l'otan mais aussi sur des
base bilatérale certains alliés le fond
c'est vrai que j'ai rencontré le
président trudeau et le canada est l'un
des pays qui apportent un soutien
bilatéral à l'ukraine et dans le
communiqué dans les décisions que nous
avons prises aujourd'hui nous avons
rappelé la décision de la porte ouverte
de l'otan décision qui a été prise au
sommet de bucarest en 2008
nous confirmons cette porte ouverte nous
avons dit que nous donnerions coup
d'accélérateur sur ce dossier et que
l'ukraine et la géorgie pays qui aspire
à l'adhésion se voit demander de
renforcer leurs réformes dans le chemin
vers l'adhésion à l'otan
cbc quatrième rang le sécrétaire général
cvc merci de prendre ma question
suite la question posée sur l'ukraine
est sûre le plan d'action pour
l'adhésion
donc il s'agit au goût des circonstances
dans lesquelles la russie permettrait à
l'ukraine de rejoindre l'otan
autre question y at il une unanimité
entre alliés pour dire que la chine en
tant que tel est une menace pour la
sécurité
je crois qu'il est extrêmement important
de souligner que chaque pays a le droit
de choisir sa propre destinée et cela
inclut aussi les accords de sécurité
auxquels ce pays souhaite adhérer c'est
à dire adhérer à l'otan ou non le
message est qu'il appartient à l'ukraine
et au 30 alliés de décider quand
l'ukraine pourra adhérer à l'alliance
la russie n'a pas son mot à dire
la russie ne peut pas opposer son veto
aux décisions de ses voisins
nous ne pouvons pas retourner à cette
heure des sphères d'influencé et où les
grandes puissances disait aux autres
pays ce qu'il devait faire
je prendrai mon pays comme exemple la
norvège est un petit pays qui a une
frontière avec la russie et l'union
soviétique n'a pas apprécié qu'en 49
nous rejoignons l'otan mais vu que les
alliés étaient fermement en faveur de
l'adhésion d'un petit pays voisins de la
russie en son sein et bien c'est comme
cela que la norvège est devenue membre
et puis la macédoine du nord plus
récemment le monténégro il y a un petit
peu plus de temps donc nous respectons
le droit de chaque pays des alliés des
30 alliés et de l'ukraine de décider si
et quand l'ukraine sera prête à
l'adhésion vous verrez que le langage à
gré du communiqué parle d'eux
du comportement coercitif de la chine
l'acquisition de nouveaux systèmes de
missiles notamment des missiles
nucléaires mais aussi les libellés sur
les attaques contre l' ordre mondial
fondé sur les règles tout cela pose des
défis de sécurité à l'alliance c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce que nous disons
dans le communiqué d'un message clair et
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
nous avons pris ces décisions les
décisions concrètes de l'agenda autant
l'idée étant de garder une supériorité
technologique et lorsque nous avons créé
l'accélérateur technologique diana c'est
pour justement garder cet avantage
technologique dans le monde par rapport
à la chine
alors lorsque nous sommes préoccupés du
contrôle et de la prise de contrôle de
la chine sur des grosses infrastructures
la 5g des infrastructures essentielles
des aéroports et bien cela veut dire que
nous devons développer notre résilience
établir des objectifs de résilience
nationaux pour se protéger pas
uniquement du défi chinois mais aussi de
tout autre défi potentiel en
l'occurrence ici notamment le défi que
présente la chine
s'agissant de l'espace c'est aussi
quelque chose que nous voyons a émané de
la chine
enfin nous devons également et nous
souhaitons également travailler plus
étroitement avec l'australie le japon
les pays de l'asie-pacifique c'est
également une manière de répondre à une
chine qui s'affirme de plus en plus en
question au deuxième rang russie merci
beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire général
vous
ce avait mentionné la politique de la
porte ouverte et l' élargissement futur
de l'alliance après avoir parlé au
leader de l'alliance pourriez vous dire
quelques mots sur l'adhésion éventuelle
future de l'âge et angers et de ce que
sont les obstacles principaux à
l'adhésion de la géorgie la question
essentielle en géorgie pour le moment et
pourquoi la géorgie n'était pas encore
membre de l'otan merci le message n'a
pas changé
comme je viens de le dire pour l'ukraine
les alliés de l'otan de l'otan sont
solidaires de la géorgie nous
fournissons en appui politique pratique
à la géorgie nous n'accepterons jamais
que des parties de la géorgie ne soit
pas mais très maîtrisé par la géorgie
est justement la quasi l'asia society
nous allons renforcer notre appui pour
la géorgie je pense au centre de
formation à l'extérieur de tbilissi et
nous allons apporter notre soutien
d'autres façons les alliés s'engage à
offrir ce soutien les engagés souhaite
aussi clairement exprimé que la géorgie
est un partenaire qui a une grande
valeur pour nous dans la région de la
mer noire et nous allons continuer à
leur offrir un appui pratique
c'est ensuite aux 30 alliée à la géorgie
de décider quand le temps est venu pour
la géorgie d'adhérer à l'otan
les décisions devront être prises par la
géorgie et les allées je ne peux pas
vous donner de date mais nous allons
continuer à appuyer les efforts de
réforme en cours et qui rapproche la
géorgie de l'otan politico
merci de votre personnel politique comme
secrétaire général
retournons sur la chine instants avec
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement avez
vous abordé la préoccupation de certains
alliés qui est que si la chine n'a parts
n'apparaît pas dans les communiqués
c'est parque au titre du traité de
washington
l'alliance n'a pas le droit de
fonctionner en dehors de la zone
atlantique et ne pensez vous pas que le
traité doit être amendé pour dire que
l'otan est prête à intervenir en dehors
de la zone euro atlantique si elle
perçoit une menace aujourd'hui
tout d'abord nous sommes déjà présents
en dehors du territoire autant nous
savons ses opérations depuis la fin de
la guerre froide
c'est un échange que nous avons eu au
début des années 90 vous avez raison
soit l'otan fermé ses portes soit elle
agit au delà de ses frontières c'est son
avis et nous nous sommes déplacés en
bosnie herzégovine par exemple nous
avons aidé à mettre fin à une guerre
violente là bas nous savons aussi
quelques années plus tard aidé à mettre
fin aux atrocités et au combat au kosovo
après les attaques du 11 septembre enfin
depuis ces attaques nous avons été
justement au premier rang de la lutte
antiterroriste et terrorisme nous avons
été en afghanistan à la frontière avec
la chine
donc ce n'est rien de totalement nouveau
cette idée de se rendre en dehors de
notre territoire c'est quelque chose que
nous faisons depuis des décennies mais
j'en retire mon message principal pour
répondre au défi qui que représente la
chine pour notre sécurité
il ne s'agit pas pour cela de déplacés
l'otan vers l'asie dont il s'agit de
prendre des mesures
ici la résilience la technologie la
cyberdéfense nous voyons que la chine se
rapproche de nous pas besoin donc de
changer le traité de l'otan pour traiter
de ces questions
l'otan va continuer à faire ce qu'elle
fait depuis plus de 70 ans protéger
défendre les alliés de toute menace
quelle qu'elle soit
par contre les menaces et des filles ont
changé la façon dont nous travaillons
change bien évidemment
nous avons il est évolué évalué que
l'instabilité dans le balcon est une
menace pour nous pendant la guerre
froide il y avait un ennemi une menace
l'union soviétique c'était simple depuis
le monde est devenu quelques pu quelque
peu plus complexe et la force de l'otan
c'est sa capacité à s'adapter à répondre
à un monde plus complexe et c'est ce que
nous allons continuer de faire l'otan
2030 justement s'intéresse à la façon
dont nous pouvons rester fiable à nos
tâches fondamentales qui vise à protéger
défendre tous les alibis dans ce monde
en permanente évolution
il s'agit donc vraiment de réfléchir à
ce que nous faisons au sein de notre
territoire
quand nous voyons que la chine se
rapproche de nous dans le cyber
contrôler nos infrastructures est
présente en afrique dans l'arctique
qu'elle s'entraîne avec la russie dans
des eaux de l'atlantique nord c'est
important pour le temps thp gueule mac
os bacad hp2 le monsieur le secrétaire
général
si l'on regarde les défis que pose la
chine où vous que vous mentionnez maints
observateurs qui connaît moins la
situation risque de dire mais la chine
n'est pas c'est un adversaire mais il y
a énormément d'allier qui sont qui ont
des liens étroits avec la chine et je
pense à l'allemagne notamment dans
quelle mesure ces liens économiques
vient-il bloquer des mesures qui
pourraient être prises pour répondre à
ces défis de sécurité sont avant toute
chose il faut bien comprendre que nous
devons à répondre à ces défis relevés au
défi que représente la montée en
puissance de la chine et aux incidences
sur notre sécurité
même si de nombreux alliés ont des liens
économiques avec la chine
finalement c'est ce que nous disons dans
le communiqué aujourd'hui également
donc il ne s'agit pas de choisir une
voie ou l'autre il ne s'agit pas dire
soit on ne fait rien et on a ces
échanges commerciaux soit on agit il n'y
a plus d' échanges commerciaux dans le
monde n'est pas si simple
ce qui est important aujourd'hui donc à
mes yeux c'est que bien entendu les
alliés individuel de l'otan ont saisi
les opportunités et les défis liés à la
montée en puissance de la chine et ça
fait de nombreuses années que c'est le
cas ce qui est nouveau maintenant ce que
nous avons observé aujourd'hui c'est que
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
dire que nous devons avancer ensemble en
tant qu'alliance en effet nous
comprenons que nous devons nous tenir
côte à côte puisque la chine sera
bientôt la plus grande puissance
économique mondiale
même les états unis finalement qui était
la plus grande puissance quasiment dans
tous les domaines même les etats-unis se
rend bien compte très clairement que
quand il s'agit de la chine
c'est un grand avantage pour les états
unis que d'avoir ses 29 amis et alliés
je pense donc que nous pouvons renforcer
une cyber défense nous pouvons payer à
ne pas avoir des systèmes 5g vulnérables
nous pouvons veiller encore une fois à
investir dans les technologies de pointe
nous pouvons travailler sur la maîtrise
des armements avec la chine
continuer à échanger avec eux sur le
plan commercial
il ne s'agit donc pas pour moi de
choisir une voie ou l'autre mais de se
tenir côte à côte pour être plus forts
en avant la ligne d'échappement agency
nova au second
merci tu au lit à torby johnny jane
sanyo va agences de presse italiennes
monsieur le secrétaire général une
question avez vous abordé le flanc sud
la région de la méditerranée et deuxième
question s'agissant de l'afghanistan et
de l'agenda autant 2030
quid de votre présence en afghanistan
qu'allez-vous faire sur ce dossier
et pensez vous qu'il est important de
retirer ce genre d'intervention de la
caisse à outils de l'otan stoos cost sur
la méditerranée et le sud oui ce sont
des sujets que nous avons abordés dans
le cadre de nos réunions l'otan doit
pouvoir répondre aux menaces et aux
défis et mal an de toute direction
nous sommes présents en irak dans le
cadre de nos efforts pour lutter contre
la résurgence de death nous travaillons
sur notre mission de formation là bas
nous sommes convaincus que la prévention
vaut mieux que l'intervention il s'agit
de stabiliser notre voisinage
grâce à la formation et le renforcement
des capacités nous travaillons aussi
avec les pas des partenaires de la
méditerranée
nous savons ce partenariat avec la
mauritanie nous essayons de voir si nous
pourrions faire davantage avec eux
notamment dans la région du sahel ce
sont des questions à discuter entre
alliés à discuter aussi avec la
mauritanie différents alliés bien
entendu se préoccupent tout
particulièrement de la situation là bas
nous particulièrement je pense à la
libye sur l'afghanistan maintenant oui
nous mettons fin à la mission résolu de
supporter
par contre nous allons continuer à
appuyer les afghans et ceux de quatre
façons au moins tout d'abord nous allons
financer les forces de sécurité afghanes
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
afghanistan il ya près de l'intense et
il y avait quasiment pas de forces de
sécurité afghanes
maintenant il y a environ 3000 personnes
et tous les alliés honteux se sont
engagés à continuer à les financer c'est
essentiel deuxièmement nous essayons de
voir comment nous pouvons organiser la
formation à l'étranger de forces de
sécurité afghanes tout particulièrement
pour les forces d'opérations spéciales
troisièmement nous avons décidé de
maintenir une présence civile en
afghanistan pour fournir encore une fois
et développement capacitaires et
quatrièmement nous allons travailler
d'arrache-pied pour préserver les
infrastructures critiques comme par
exemple l'aéroport pour permettre la
présence de l'otan la présence civil de
l'otan sur place
mais pour permettre aussi la présence de
la communauté internationale de façon
générale présence diplomatique mais
présence aussi de l'aide humanitaire
donc voilà quatre façon dont nous allons
continuer à offrir notre appui
merci beaucoup je sais qu'il y as
d'autres questions mais nous allons
devoir arrêter là merci beaucoup merci
et bonne soirée